hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2018 chinese comedy in action movie
called kung fu league
the movie begins with a kung fu master
called ying xiong who is trying to save
her girlfriend from bandits he comes
alone and is cornered by them but ying
effortlessly defeats all the bandits the
bandit leader who seems to be a worthy
opponent for yang shows up and fights
yang however ying is still too strong
for him and the bandit leader eventually
begs for mercy turns out that the scene
was just a comic that was created by
ying a 25 years old cartoonist who loves
to write a comic book about kung fu
he plans to send a love letter to his
co-worker bower but he suddenly collides
with her causing the papers to scatter
on the floor
while bauer tries to help him suddenly
the president of the company zhang shows
up and intervenes
it seems like zhong also has a crush on
her and immediately takes her away
the heartbroken ying goes to his aunt
who also works in the company as a
janitor and complains to her
she suggests ying has to express his
feelings to her as soon as possible
before it's too late as that day is
ying's birthday the aunt hands him a
tiny birthday gift and tells him to make
a wish
just after the ant leaves ying spots
bauer's bag and attempts to slip the
love letter however a colleague sees him
and accuses him of trying to steal from
bauer's bag
ying becomes panicked and hits him with
a bag which causes everyone to gather
including the boss
being insulted ying gets angry and walks
away
that evening the devastated ying opens
the tiny cake and wishes that all kung
fu masters he drew come to reality and
help him to get bauer's heart
surprisingly the cake grants his wish
and the masters from the paper start
talking to him
the scene moves to master huang
fe-hong's era where a beautiful lady is
confused to decide whether she should
choose wong or mr x
meanwhile in a lion dance battle wong
shows off his kung fu skill and manages
to defeat his foe the lady writes a
letter and orders her assistant to send
the letter to someone in shanghai
indicating that she has eventually
chosen wong over mr x after the battle
master wong returns to his place and
randomly proposes to the lady in front
of his supporters but it seems like the
lady is still having a hard time to
forget mr x in his dream master wong is
approached by yin who begs to help him
and tells him three random numbers one
five and two
after the encounter wong wakes up and
finds himself already in a shooting
studio he gets confused as everything
around him becomes very modern and
attempts to escape but he coincidentally
meets chen zhen in the process the
masters decide to run away after
rejecting the film director's offers to
take part in his movie
chen tells wong that he also had a
strange dream and shows him a paper
revealing that they had traveled through
time to 2018. they explore the city and
eventually meet the other masters yip
man and chen's teacher master huo
turns out that master huo was mr x and
he is afraid that wong would find out
that he's having an affair with his
fiancee
all of them had the same dream and were
also given three random numbers by ying
except yep man who experienced nothing
they try to crack the code which they
believe will lead them to yang
[Music]
long story short they arrive at the
center of the city while chan and huo
try to read the map wong is given a
leaflet which eventually leads them to a
fast food restaurant
upon arrival the masters are shocked and
confused with the present food
since they have no money at all the
waiter suggests they kiss to get free
food
bower who is also eating at the
restaurant spots them and offers them
more burgers
she also gives them money
however since when does yip man learn to
smoke a present cigarette
this yip man wannabe then takes all the
money but suddenly gets stolen by a
rider chen manages to break the
motorcycle but the thief runs away and
the masters chase after him
he flees to his hideout and asks for
help there
since they are kung fu masters they beat
everyone easily
they even humiliate the gangsters the
leader concedes defeat and promises to
return the money but the masters claim
they don't need money
thus the leader offers to help them find
yin since he and his men are i.t experts
after telling them about the random
numbers from the dream they try to crack
the code and eventually discover that
random numbers are actually a phone
number when the leader attempts to call
the number suddenly a phone from a
gangster's bag rings
turns out that the phone was yang's
which was stolen in the subway
lucky for them ying uses his own face as
a wallpaper on his phone so they can
easily find him later after they learn
that ying is going to a martial arts
contest
afterwards the gangster leader assists
them to sneak into the venue while
sneaking through a storeroom the fakeyip
man accidentally finds wong's fiancee's
letter and hands it over to him this
finding makes chan and master huo panic
lucky for chen wang decides to open the
letter later after they hear noises from
a distance
at the center stage it is seen president
zhang is talking to bower while yin
eavesdrops from under the table
zhang expresses his feelings to the
woman even after knowing that bauer's
heart belongs to ying which is heard by
ying
just before ying wants to intervene
master wong arrives and pulls him away
however they are spotted by zhong's
henchman who immediately chases them and
fights wong
after a rough fight that destroys the
entire stage the masters and ying run
away from the building
on the other hand zhong is disappointed
when he figures out that bauer came to
the venue to see ying the master is
politely asking to bring them back to
their time but ying shows them a leaflet
of a martial arts tournament and asks
them to teach him kung fu instead
he wants to win the 4.5 million dollars
prize so that no one will insult him as
a poor man again
the next day they gather at a football
stadium where the first day of the
training takes place however instead of
teaching yin kung fu the masters
especially master huo show off their
skills and humiliate ying
huo estimates that ying needs
approximately 30 years to master kung fu
the nerd refuses since he needs a faster
way
wong explains that there is another
alternative which is to open up his
seven chakras channel with external
force
the confident ying immediately calls a
woman to step on his crotch to unlock
his root chakra but is later taken to
hospital instead
long story short the martial arts
tournament begins and everyone gathers
at the competition venue wong gives ying
an opportunity to express his feelings
directly to bow ur but suddenly jong
intervenes and gives ying his phone
turns out that it's his aunt calling
from the hospital
she informs yang that her son is dying
and asks him to lend her some money for
the surgery while suggesting he lets
bauer go
after the call ying withdraws his
intention to confess
they decide to go to a bar where ying
contemplates his fate being a poor boy
and a loser
suddenly the drunken master wong appears
and encourages ying to be brave
later that night ying who disguises
himself as a maid sneaks into bower's
apartment and approaches her he jumps
into the pool and whispers to her that
he didn't steal any of her stuff at the
office earlier he then gets up and
reveals that he put a love letter into
her bag
however ying opens a wrong love letter
turns out that bower also wrote a love
letter which is addressed to ying
ying continues reading bower's letter
and it is revealed that the woman has
been in love with ying since college
the nerd immediately jumps back into the
pool and kisses his long-awaited lover
the following day wong who takes part in
the tournament is seen emotionless and
enters the boxing ring
he awkwardly requests his foe to beat
him ruthlessly and wants to be killed by
him the scene moves to the day before
the competition when master wong
desperately wanted to end his life since
he was not able to meet his fiancee the
others managed to prevent him from doing
so but master huo got hurt after getting
hit by the falling ceiling
back in the ring master wong indeed lets
his opponent hit him repeatedly and he
doesn't respond back at all
master huo is furious when seeing wong
get beaten up and decides to intervene
in the battle
because of that the situation in the
venue becomes chaotic
master huo runs to wang and scolds him
for being a coward while confessing that
he had an affair with his fiancee
not long after ying appears and
encourages wong to fight back if he
wants to see his fiance again
master wong suddenly becomes motivated
and challenges his opponent confidently
he manages to knock him down
effortlessly even after he gives a tough
fight
meanwhile bauer is captured by zhong and
he orders yang from a voicemail to get
into an elevator if he wants to save her
ying and the masters hurriedly descend
to an underground hideout while the fake
yip man finally confesses that he is
actually a fugitive disguised as yip man
jong who has been waiting for them
equips himself with a special kung fu
armor which makes him a kung fu master
he deliberately invents the armor to
protect bauer from bad guys but he is
disappointed since the woman he has
loved since childhood chooses ying over
him
the fight between the masters and the
ceo ensues however the suit can analyze
each master's fighting style causing
zhong to take one step further in the
fight and beat all of them easily since
the masters stand no chance against
zhong ying has to step up in order to
rescue his lover
ying gets beaten up by the president
repeatedly and can't fight back as he
doesn't know kung fu at all
unbeknownst to him ying deliberately
keeps provoking zhang and he
accidentally unlocks ying's chakras
channels
the nerd suddenly gains enormous power
and reaches the highest level of kung fu
skills he effortlessly dodges every
incoming attack from zhang and
eventually beats him with a single blow
bauer is then rescued at the end of the
movie the fake yet man is arrested for
his crime and the masters finally
managed to travel back to their era
while ying and bauer live happily after
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching